nous ne pouvons pas ééberger toute la
misère du monde là on a une grande
tradition rocardienne il nomme les
choses alors Michel rckard d'abord est
premier ministre là il faut lutter
contre toute immigration nouvelle à 4
millions un peu plus
42000 étrangers en France nous ne
pouvons pas ééberger toute la misère du
monde ce n'est pas possible c'est
également l'homme à gauche du parler
vrai pour ceux qui chez nous vivent mal
parce que leurs quartiers sont dégradés
parce qu'ils n'ont pas de formation ont
pas d'emploi pas de logement qu'il soit
français ou étranger là est la politique
d'intégration de tous les démunis de la
société française il présise bien que la
tâche est la tâche de l'intégration de
tous les démunis qu'il soit français
comme immigré et il dit pour ça
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire bien faut
arrêter cette immigration cette
politique est dure mais nous devons le
faire pour maintenir la cohésion de la
société française et pour pouvoir
intégrer inséré dans des conditions
décentes ceux des immigrés qui sont chez
nous en situation régulière ce qui est
très intéressant c'est que derrière le
discours de rard il y a un doute sur la
capacité du modèle français à intégrer
on le voit dans le regard même du
Premier ministre pu faut pas oublier en
effet il y a l'affaire de
crille de ces jeunes filles en effet qui
veulent rester à l'école publique avec
le voile le Coran le foulard et le
collège à crille on ne parle que deel
trois élèves musulmanes refusent
d'enlever au nom du Coran leur foulard
pendant les cours elles ont été
provisoirement expulsé puis réintégré ça
commence à poser de manière forte la
question de la réussite de l'intégration
alors ne parlons pas de l'intégration
économique ou sociale la misère de
l'intégration culturel et puis ce qui
est très important c'est la chute de
cette petite intervention de recard il
dit mais en revanche il y a quelque
chose sur lequelle la France ne
transisera jamais c'est l'accueil des
réfugiés politiques la France doit
rester ce qu'elle est une terre d'asile
politique nous sommes signataires de la
convention de de Genève qui prévoit de
donner accueil à tout ceux dont les
libertés d'expression ou dont les
opinions sont réprimées sur place mais
pas plus je crois que la popularité de
cette phrase fait que tout le monde
presque peut la partager parce que c'est
un homme de gauche qui la prononce nous
ne pouvons pas héberger toute la misère
du monde ce n'est pas possible elle sort
de la Pan tous les hommes politiques
c'est une manière
relativement sereine d'aborder cette
question qui qui est une question
extrêmement
[Musique]
complexe